a nosotros los seres humanos nos gusta
entender la complejidad que nos rodea
por medio de la clasificación de las
cosas y como puedes imaginarte no hay
una cosa más obvia para clasificar que
todos los seres vivos que nos rodean
toda la vida que nos rodean entonces con
lo que quiero comenzar es hablando de
cómo clasificamos la vida que nos rodea
y esto a menudo se conoce como taxonomía
pero la pregunta más básica que
seguramente tienes y esto es porque
miras a tu alrededor y empiezas a ver
similitudes entre los seres vivos y por
ejemplo aquí ves que este de aquí es más
similar a las cosas que se parecen a él
que bueno el pasto que está detrás o tal
vez un árbol y entonces empezamos a
decir que a lo mejor debería de agrupar
a este animal de aquí en un grupo donde
haya cosas similares a él y el elemento
más básico en donde clasificamos a los
seres vivos que nos rodean es un
contenedor llamado
especie
100 entonces por ejemplo este de aquí es
un animal particular pero vemos a otros
animales que se parecen a él entonces
decimos que todos ellos son parte de la
especie de los leones en este caso de
los leones
y bueno este otro animal como otros
tiene rayas y bueno algunos son más
gordos otros son más altos otros son más
flacos u oscuros o claros o cualquier
otra cosa pero vemos que son lo
suficientemente similares como para que
a todos les llamemos tigres
diréis muy bien también todos los
animales que se parecen a este aunque
algunos son un poco más grandes y otros
son un poco más flacos delgados o gordos
o claros u obscuros no importa porque a
todos estos les llamamos bulos
robos y bueno también llamaríamos a
todos los animales que se parecen a este
animal los vamos a llamar a todos
caballos
que va
dios ahora bien seguramente estás
pensando que esta es una idea bastante
sencilla puedes decir todo lo que se ve
como esto es un león y para todo lo que
se ve como esto es un tigre y se acabó
pero esto por sí solo no es una
definición lo suficientemente buena para
especie es decir cosas que se parecen o
actúan de la misma manera ya que como
veremos hay algunas cosas que pueden ser
muy distintas al menos en cómo se ven y
en cómo actuar pero que realmente están
muy relacionadas y hablaremos de qué
significa estar muy relacionados en un
ratito y también puede suceder el caso
contrario que veamos cosas que no son
muy similares pero que tienen
estructuras similares o que tienen un
comportamiento similar por ejemplo los
murciélagos y las aves pero realmente
tienen un parentesco muy muy lejano
entonces necesitamos una definición más
exacta para esta palabra especie algo un
poco más exacto que cosas que
simplemente se parecen o que actúan de
manera similar y para eso la definición
más típica de especie
voy a poner aquí especie va a ser cuando
tenemos organismos organismos o dan
que pueden entrecruzarse que pues de él
entre perú se hace muy bien y cuando
estoy diciendo entrecruzarse a lo que me
refiero es que pueden tener crías entre
ellos y además que esas crías son
fértiles
las crías
es decir que sus hijos pueden tener
bebés que no son estériles que son
capaces de reproducirse con otros
animales y producir más crías y bueno
esta va a ser nuestra definición de
especie y para mostrarte un ejemplo
justo de esto vamos a ver esto que
tenemos aquí aquí imagínate que tenemos
a un león que es macho y si tú te
encuentras a un león macho ya una leona
la mayoría de las veces serán capaces de
tener hijos y estas crías serán capaces
de aparearse con otros leones o leonas
dependiendo su sexo y bueno ellos pueden
tener una descendencia viable entonces
esto parece funcionar muy bien con los
leones y lo mismo sucede con los tigres
estas dos son especies
y resulta que si tú cruzas a un león
macho déjame ponerlo con este color
vamos a hablar de un león macho
y lo cruzas con una tigre que es hembra
una tigresa así que le voy a poner
hembra
entonces estos dos pueden reproducirse y
pueden producir descendencia y su
descendencia la cual se volvió famosa
por napoleon dynamite aquí le fascinaban
estos animales lo tenemos en esta foto
de aquí este de aquí es la descendencia
de un león macho y una tigresa hembra ya
éste se le conoce con el nombre de tigre
este decir es un tigre y cree el cual es
un híbrido es el producto de la cruza
entre un león y un tigre y los ligres
son los gatos más grandes que conocemos
pero estos libres no se consideran como
una especie distinta o bien podrías
decir que los leones y los tigres no son
la misma especie ya que aunque son
capaces de reproducirse y su
descendencia son los ligres esta
descendencia en su mayoría no es
el libre no es capaz de tener
descendencia y bueno hay historias
acerca de que sean cruzados libres con
ya sea un león o un tigre pero son cosas
que suceden en muy rara vez en general
los ligres no pueden reproducirse y en
general esta combinación de estos dos no
va a producir crías que puedan
reproducirse o que sean fértiles y es
por eso que decimos que los leones y los
tigres son especies distintas y de hecho
a los libres no los debemos de
considerar como una especie debemos
considerar que son un híbrido de dos
especies y tal vez te estás preguntando
ok esto sucede con un león macho y un
tigre hembra y qué pasa si es al revés
qué pasa si te tomas a un tigre que sea
macho y lo cruzas con una leona hembra
en este caso se produciría algo nuevo y
bueno la respuesta es que si en este
caso se produciría algo distinto que se
le conoce con el nombre de
creo que es digo a ti
y este es un híbrido distinto al libre y
tiene propiedades distintas a las de un
libre así que te invito a que busque es
que es un ligón y bueno lo mismo va a
suceder si tú tienes a un burro macho
iban claramente los burros son una
especie ya que si me das un burro macho
y una burra hembra estos se pueden
reproducir y producir otro burro y ese
burro puede aparearse con otros burros y
producir más y más y más burros es decir
que no solo el burro puede cruzarse con
otro burro sino también su producto ese
burro bebé y exactamente lo mismo pasa
con los caballos pueden cruzarse y
producir descendencia fértil pero si me
das un burro macho déjame ponerlo voy a
tomarme a un burro macho
y lo voy a cruzar con un caballo que sea
hembra
brad
bueno pues estos dos se pueden
reproducir y van a producir lo que se
conoce con el nombre de mula esta de
aquí es una
la una mula pero una vez más como los
ligres las mulas no son fértiles o no
son fértiles hasta donde yo sé que eso
quiere decir que las mulas no pueden
producir descendencia no pueden cruzarse
entre ellas y debido a que los burros y
los caballos pueden aparearse y producir
mulas pero su descendencia no es fértil
entonces consideramos a los burgos y a
los caballos especies distintas y
consideramos a las mulas como a los
ligres oa los tejones a estos los
consideramos híbridos así que déjenme
notarlo este de aquí es un híbrido
y este también pero en general la
palabra híbrido se usa cuando tienes dos
cosas distintas que se juntaron que de
alguna manera se combinaron y una vez
más como en el caso de los tirones qué
pasaría si se cruza una burra hembra y
un caballo macho
bueno pues ellos producirían algo que se
conoce con el nombre de burj de gano lo
cual no es tan común como las mulas y la
gente le gusta usar mulas ya que son
animales muy buenos para el trabajo
porque tienen tanto las buenas
características de los burros como las
buenas características de los caballos y
bueno los bordes -ganó son menos comunes
pero una vez más son posibles y
obviamente tienen distintas propiedades
a las mulas y realmente quiero enfatizar
esta idea la idea de especie porque
cuando empezamos este vídeo sólo
pensamos en cómo clasificar cosas
recuerdas y dijimos a lo mejor las cosas
que se ven de una manera parecida son la
misma especie ya lo mejor las cosas que
sé
y actúan distinto no son de la misma
especie pero quiero enseñarte un caso
muy típico el cual es un caso que forma
parte de nuestra vida cotidiana donde
esta definición de especie nos va a
servir mucho porque dice son organismos
que pueden entrecruzarse y las crías son
fértiles y esto parece ser que tiene
mucho más importancia que la noción de
que los organismos se parecen o actúan
de la misma manera así que para el
siguiente ejemplo voy a traer para acá a
los por acá están a los perros estos que
tenemos aquí como te dije es una especie
muy común déjame poner que son perros
y bueno los perros es una especie muy
común pero aquí tome varios ejemplos de
diferentes razas de perros se pueden ver
muy distintos entre sí obviamente tú
puedes ver que hay muchas diferencias
entre estos perros por ejemplo este
pequeño chihuahua que tenemos aquí y
este perro más grande que tenemos aquí
tienen como diferencia su tamaño como se
ven e incluso como actúan de hecho las
diferencias pueden ser mucho más
marcadas entre estos dos que entre el
burro y el caballo por ejemplo o entre
el tigre y el león y obviamente estos se
ven muy distintos porque tienen tamaño
distinto y bueno también tienen un
comportamiento distinto pero estos dos
perros se podrían aparear aunque bueno
en particular para estos dos parece que
la mecánica hace que esto sea un poco
difícil pero bueno suponiendo que
pudieran superar los obstáculos
mecánicos ellos podrían aparearse y
producir descendencia fértil lo mismo
sucede con
estos dos perros o tal vez estos dos
perros qué sé yo lo que quiero decirte
es que debido a esto todas las distintas
razas de perros y ojos la mayoría de
ellas surgieron gracias a que los
humanos intentaban crear características
específicas aunque todos estos se vean
distintos y actúen de maneras distintas
estas razas de perros pueden aparearse y
producir descendencia fértil y es por
eso que consideramos a todas las
distintas razas de perros miembros de la
misma especie